the word trauma meaning a terrible event
we live through that cannot be
remembered but which generates painful
related symptoms captures an acute
paradox in our relationship to our own
histories
some of what is most significant in our
lives is inaccessible to day-to-day
memory the more important something is
the less we may be able to recall it
there seems to be a threshold of pain
above which our minds won't go in order
to retrieve an event
we'll recall with ease the pleasant
childhood spring morning 30 years ago by
the riverbank when we swam and fed the
ducks but we'll be sincerely unable to
remember a moment that same day when our
troubled father abruptly lost his temper
over an apparent triviality and from
nowhere slapped us extremely hard across
the cheek and left us to walk home alone
the memory retrieving part of our minds
is like an eye that clenches shut in the
presence of a flash and closes down when
asked to archive and then recover
incidents of intense fury or terror
ridicule or shame the difficulties may
be very large a bomb a physical
violation or apparently more modest
mockery an unexplained burst of fury a
prolonged absence
yet what defines a trauma is not so much
an objective score on a scale of
awfulness as a subjective impression
that an incident is too difficult for us
to make sense of it's too much at odds
with our models of reality and poses too
great a risk to our hopes of ourselves
and those we want to love
though we may be nominally protected by
our ignorance of our traumas the overall
impact of our disconnection has the
power to derail our lives
we may not have kept in mind that our
father was a deeply vengeful and
frightening man but it's on exactly this
basis that we have begun to fear all men
and to despise our whole being we may
not remember our mother's terrifying
competitiveness but its submerged
presence is what has bred in us a
deleteriously shy manner and a habit of
removing ourselves from any position
where we may triumph and be admired by
others
problems don't go away because they have
been sent to a catacomb they have a
greater impact precisely because they
can't be brought to consciousness and
resolved through conversation and
sympathetic analysis
the challenge of recovering from trauma
is that we can't on command remember
what we do not know we have even
forgotten
we need to proceed indirectly awakening
ourselves to the possibility of buried
difficulties on the basis of a range of
otherwise inexplicable present day fears
and ticks when there is no obvious
reason for our body dysmorphia or
shyness impotence or insomnia paranoia
or despair we should start to dig in the
presence of those who love us and
understand our minds to prevent our
stories from being controlled by figures
of our personal histories who did not
have our interests at heart
we need to retrieve as much of our pasts
as will be required to embark on the
free adult lives we deserve
our therapists are highly trained and
accredited
and are a vital source of kindness
solace and wisdom for life's most
difficult moments
click the link to find out more
you